THE SHOW.
NOT GETTING ENOUGH A'S.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BEGIN THIS WEDNESDAY WITH FOX
NEWS ALERT.
JOE BIDEN CAUGHT MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS YET AGAIN.
SECOND TIME THIS WEEK, LEARNING
SECRET MATERIAL FROM OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TURNED UP IN
ANOTHER PRIVATE UNSECURED OFFICE
ACCESSED BY JOE BIDEN AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN.
I THINK IT IS TIME FOR
MAR-A-LAGO-STYLED RAID.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING, TWICE IN
A WEEK COULD THIS BE RESULT.
MAYBE SOMEONE DOESN'T WANT JOE
TO RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
SUSPICIOUS IN TERMS OF TIMING.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
PERSONALLY APPROVED OF THE RAID
AT MAR-A-LAGO AT FORMER DONALD
TRUMP'S HOME.
THIS IS WHY THE INVESTIGATION
INTO WHETHER OR NOT OUR FBI IS
POLITICIZED AND DOJ WEAPONIZED
IS SO IMPORTANT.
MANY OF AMERICA'S POWERFUL
BUREAUCRATS USING POWERFUL
POSITIONS TO REPUN REPUBLICANS
AND PROTECT DEMOCRATS.
CRIMINAL INFORMATION WOULD
ALREADY BE UNDERWAY.
JOE BIDEN AGREES MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL IS EGREGIOUS
OFFENSE.
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS OWN WORDS.
>> WHEN YOU SAW THE PHOTOGRAPH
OF TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS WHAT DID
YOU THINK TO YOURSELF LOOKING AT
THAT IMAGE?
>> HOW THAT COULD POSSIBLY
HAPPEN?
HOW ANYONE COULD BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE.
WHAT DATA WAS IN THERE THAT MAY
COMPROMISE SOURCES, METHODS.
NAMES OF PEOPLE THAT HELPED,
ETC. TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Sean: HOW, JOE, HOW COULD
THAT HAPPEN?
TODAY VERY OWN PETER DOOCY.
NOT ABLE TO ANSWER THE QUESTION,
SHE HAD A TOUGH DAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW COULD ANYONE BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE?
ISN'T THAT WHAT THIS PRESIDENT
SAYS ABOUT MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
>> HE BELIEVES CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION SHOULD
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
HE TAKES THEM SERIOUSLY.
HE WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN -- I G
DISAGREE.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED ONCE --
>> WHY IS THERE A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> LET ME EXPLAIN THE PROCESS.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
LAWYERS FOUND OUT, IMMEDIATELY
TURNED THEM OVER TO THE ARCHIVES
>> THEY DID THE RIGHT THING.
>> I AM NOT GOING INTO
SPECIFICS.
WHAT I AM REITERATED TO YOU WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM THE PRESIDENT
YOURSELF, PETER.
HOW HE SAW THE PROCESS.
HOW HE RESPECTS AND TRULY
RESPECTS AND TAKES THIS
SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: HOW CAN ONE BE SO
IRRESPONSIBLE?
BIDEN TAKES IT SO SERIOUSLY.
HE LEFT CLASSIFIED MATERIAL
BEHIND.
JOE BIDEN IS ALLOWED TO
MISHANDLE TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP IS ACCUSED IT
BECOMES A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
"WASHINGTON POST," FACT CHECKER
WHO IS GOING TO FACT CHECK THE
FACT CHECKER.
MAY NEED TO FACT CHECK HIMSELF.
ASSOCIATED PRESS, "NEW YORK
TIMES" THEY DID THE SAME,
RUNNING COVER FOR JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE EXTENSION OF THE WHITE
HOUSE PRESS HOURS.
FAKE NEWS CNN, CLEAR
DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN THE TWO
CASES, NEW CONTROVERSY SO FAR
APPEARS TO BE ON A SMALLER
SCALE.
NOW GETTING BIGGER.
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE TWO CASES.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, DONALD TRUMP
PRESIDENT.
DONALD TRUMP HAD THE POWER TO
DECLASSIFY ANYTHING WHEN THESE
DOCUMENTS WERE TRANSPORTED TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
BY THE WAY NO SET PROCESS FOR
DECLASSIFICATION.
JOE BIDEN AS VICE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T HAVE THAT POWER.
SECOND DONALD TRUMP'S STORIED IN
A ROOM EXAMINED SPECIFICALLY BY
THE FBI.
ASKED DONALD TRUMP AND TEAM TO
SECURE THAT ROOM WITH A PADLOCK.
AT THEIR REQUEST HE DID SO.
BY THE WAY, FULL TIME SECURITY
CAMERAS ON THAT DOOR.
EE
BIDEN'S DOCUMENTS -- BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY CHINA.
54 PLUS MILLION DOLLARS CHINA
DONATE
DONATED.
THIRD DOCUMENTS OF MAR-A-LAGO
RECOVERED BY FORCE LESS THAN TWO
YEARS.
BY CONTRAST, PRESENT BIDEN LEFT
THEM DANGLING IN THE WIND FOR
SIX YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY NEEDS
TO DO DAMAGE AND RISK ASSESSMENT
HOW DONALD TRUMP'S HANDLING
MIGHT HAVE HARMED OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> THIS IS POLITICIZED.
IMAGINE IT IS ALREADY
POLITICIZED BY THOSE ON THE
RIGHT AND FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> IF THE TRUMP PEOPLE
CLASSIFIED AND DIDN'T, THAT IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
>> WE SEE NO EVIDENCE.
>> THIS WAS NOT A MISTAKE THESE
DOCUMENTS LANDED AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THIS IS WHAT HE INTENDED.
SHOWS THEY REALLY WANT TO GET
DOCUMENTS BACK.
EVERY SECOND THEY ARE AT THIS
BEACH HOUSE IN THE POSSESSION OF
DONALD TRUMP IS A RISK.
>> WE ALL KNOW TRUMP IS A LIAR
AND A THIEF.
[APPLAUSE]
IT IS NOT THAT BIG OF JUMP TO
SAY HE OBSTRUCTED AND LIED.
WE DON'T THINK BIDEN IS A LIAR
AND THIEF.
>> Sean: AMERICA'S ONCE TRUSTED
INSTITUTIONS THEY ARE WORSE.
LOOK AT THE TWO TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THEY TREATED CAPITOL RIOTERS.
574 RIOTS SUMMER 2020.
DOZENS OF DEAD AMERICANS.
BILLIONS IN PROPERTY DAMAGE.
THOUSANDS OF INJURED COPS T.
INVESTIGATED DONALD TRUMP OVER
RUSSIA HOAX.
EXFOREIGN SPY A MILLION DOLLARS
TO MAKE IT TRUE.
THEY WON'T TOUCH BRIBERY
ALLEGATIONS.
THEY CONDUCTED EARLY MORNING
RAIDS AGAINST NUMEROUS TRUMP
ASSOCIATES.
NOT EVEN HUNTER WHO -- GETS ANY
OF THE SAME TREATMENT.
THEY GIVE HILARY CLINTON.
SHE WAS THE WORST OF EVERYBODY.
FREE PASS.
SHE MISS HANDLED TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
SHE DEDELETED 33,000 E-MAILS TO
TAKE COVER IN TERMS OF RECORD
AND BACKGROUND.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY SAID
OR WHERE THEY ARE.
DEMOCRACY DIES IN DARKNESS OR A
CUTE MODEL AND NOT A PRINCIPLE
BELIEF SO CALLED JOURNALIST,
NEARLY EVERY NEWS OUT